hier montré du doigt réservé aux adeptes
d'une contre culture underground le pire
singh se dévoile aujourd'hui au grand
jour et sans complexe
ouais
comme cette expérience
pourquoi parce que je trouvais ça super
mignon c'est joli et pour les faits je
trouve c'est
trouée dans l'oreille le nez ou la
langue comme sonia ou alexandre ils sont
environ cent mille chaque année à passer
la porte des boutiques spécialisées
depuis trois ans cette petite boule
d'acier a changé de statut
objet symbole d'une population marginale
dans les années 80 la pratique du
piercing s'adressent désormais un large
public
après le voile islamique le piercing
provoque la polémique au lycée et cette
première qui étonne jusqu'au ministère
de l'éducation nationale s'est passé au
lycée professionnel vauvert de bourges
une élève qui portait un piercing à
l'arcade sourcilière est passé à deux
doigts d'exclusion tout est rentré dans
l'ordre mais le proviseur entend
modifier le règlement intérieur de
l'établissement pour interdire ce
piercing visible tout au moins le
reportage de david gill et daniel le
floch
l'objet du délit pour ce pire signal à
l'arcade sourcilière et le dire ans on a
bien failli être renvoyé du lycée en
début de semaine d'abord c'est l'épreuve
qui me dit que c'était interdit
alors que c'était pas marqué dans le
règlement et donc j'ai été convoqué au
bureau plusieurs fois ils m'ont dit de
mettre un pansement et je n'ai pas mis
j'ai pas voulu parce que franchement je
pense que c'est encore plus ridicule qu
un piercing et puis après j'ai été une
deuxième fois convoqué dans le bureau de
la directrice
et puis là voulaient me renvoyer voulait
me faire signer une décharge comme quoi
j'ai démissionné deux fois je pense que
les gens ils ont pas ils ont pas les
comprennent pas les moeurs fois qu'on a
aujourd'hui pour les temps changent et
puis voilà quoi soutenu par les élèves
de sa classe et d'autres qui ont fait
grève
elodie rançon a été de nouveau admise en
cours vu la proximité de l'examen et je
cite à condition que ses cheveux cash
l'objet du délit
aujourd'hui les enseignants jouent
l'apaisement pas les lycéens et le
diable dans ma classe si ça fait quatre
ans ya jamais eu de problème apparemment
c'est une bonne élève à la bonne note
donc je comprends pas au fait je pense
plutôt que c'est un avis personnel par
rapport à aux proviseurs novi sad être
son avis personnel parce que ça gêne pas
s'en rend pas les jambes est donc moi je
suis pas d'accord avec ce qu'est ce que
c'est de la discrimination contre le
pire singh dans l'établissement madame
le proviseur du lycée vauvert assume
elle précise que c'est une décision
collective et son souci préparer au
mieux ces lycéens à la vie
professionnelle
nous avons je pense un devoir de
d'éducation il me semble que ce n'est
pas pour nos élèves comment on pourrait
dire si ça ne donne pas une belle image
de ses enfants
voilà ce que je ressens on l'a vue venir
avec la techno c'est comme au moment où
il y avait les skinheads c'était un fait
de société
face à ce problème de société un nouveau
règlement intérieur sera proposé au
conseil d'administration du lycée pour
la rentrée prochaine affaire interne ou
une cas d'école le rectorat n'a pas
souhaité faire de commentaire
ce matin izilda n'est pas resté plus
d'une demi heure dans son collège
enfin moi je trouve ça inadmissible
apparemment les professeurs refusent de
la réintégrer un cours bon il n'a pas
été possible d'aller voir les
professeurs puisque madame lescure nous
interdit d'y aller izilda c'est super
l'enfant par en pleurant elle croyait
retourner dans sa classe avec ses
copains tout ce qu'on lui propose c'est
de se retrouver seul face à un
professeur mise à l'écart à cause du
pire signe qu'elle porte sous les lèvres
moi j'appelle ça de la ségrégation mais
bon eux ils appellent ça un compromis
hier nous avions rencontré izilda chez
elle confiante une semaine d'exclusion
elle pensait avoir assez cher payé sa
fantaisie
moi je n'ai rien dit parce que même pas
la preuve du ps espoir et eu deux puits
de secours à m'inscrire pour un piercing
que j'ai depuis un mois et demi quand je
suis bon élève et je travaillais à 8
heures la principale du collège n'a pas
voulu s'exprimer publiquement
elle nous a expliqué que les enfants de
cet âge ont besoin de règles précises au
nom de l'égalité pas de piercing pas non
plus de cheveux de couleur dans son
établissement
un peu d'accord égalité c'est pas
uniformité et bon l'école publique c'est
l'école de tous c'est l'école des
différences je crois qu'il faut qu'on
fasse en sorte de
de scolariser tous les enfants en
respectant leur personnalité et puis
tout à coup à 11 heures nous apprenons
résultat pourra réintégrer normalement
son collège cet après midi non c'est sa
vie c'est pas celle des pro à par
exemple
sinon évidemment un piercing c'est leur
choix c'est pas la peine de faire tout
ça pour juste une couleur et un piercing
c'est n'importe quoi ya des problèmes
plus graves que ça le collège de coursan
va peut-être enfin retrouver un peu de
sérénité
ah bon voilà dans ces conditions oui ma
fuite je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous sur ce point de vue sans aucun
problème et je vous remercie beaucoup
monsieur
or voilà soulagés la mère de sabrina
le proviseur du lycée professionnel
toulouse-lautrec d'albi vient d'annoncer
la réintégration de sa fille en classe
depuis une dizaine de jours
l'adolescente de 17 ans élève en
terminale employés et techniciens des
collectivités n'étaient plus admises en
cours motif invoqué son refus de retirer
ses piercings et plus particulièrement
celui du menton saisi hier soir de la
faire l'inspection académique
dédramatise la situation
on cherche quand même des milliers des
milliers d'élèves dans chaque
établissement il ya des dizaines des
centaines
c'est bien qu'il ya des règles du jeu
collective pour si dans ce domaine là ça
aboutit à avoir un refus telle qu'on
aurait arrivera une déscolarisation
c'est absurde
par contre de retravailler sur le
l'objectif premier qui donnerait du sens
pour retraite ce piercing ça nous paraît
plus pédagogique
simplement cela pour le proviseur le
lycée professionnel doit appliquer les
mêmes règles que le monde du travail ce
que conteste sabrina si je trouve un
emploi là où ils les enlèvent répond
pour l'instant vidéo sur le sable sont
dans un lycée public
donc je les laisse coi pour l'instant
demain sabrina c'est pire si nous
retrouvons le lycée en attendant une
révision du règlement intérieur
[Musique]